hello there so just like the trailer for
man lauren season three the trailer for
ahsoka has also leaked and i'm going to
break down some details that have been
seen in this trailer so we have some
shots of ahsoka inside of a ship of some
kind and then many shots of her just
traversing through different
environments and then a shot of her
walking through some runes with her
cloak on and then we see a shot of hera
sandula this is our first time we've
seen this character in live action so
really exciting stuff here we have a
shot of a soaker where she pulls back
her hood to reveal herself there's one
key detail here that is a big change
from her appearances in the mandalorian
and that change is that her head tail
pieces are longer so remember there's
actually a lot of complaints back in
amanda lauren saying her head tails were
too short but now her leku is longer and
it's more accurate to her character and
then to end of the trailer we have a
shot of sabine here which is also a
character we haven't seen in live action
yet as she firstly appeared in star wars
rebels anyway that's pretty much
everything about this video so the link
to this trailer will be in the
description below watch it before it
gets taken down and if you did enjoy
this video please like and subscribe and
turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching